c'est la version européenne de la grande
marche de la présidentielle de 2016 le
parti des manuels macron se lance dans
les élections européennes de 2019
en partant à la rencontre des français
on a besoin d'aller à la rencontre des
français comme on l'avait fait en 2016
est là pour parler de l'europe savoir ce
qu'ils en attente qui marche qui marche
pas ce qui va nous permettra de
construire ce projet européen qui ne
servira de base pour les élections
européennes de 2009
moi je pense qu'il faut donner aux
citoyens le goût de l'europe parce que
on voit bien que depuis des années les
participations aux élections européennes
par exemple elles baissent de plus en
plus parce que les gens ne vois pas où
est l'utilité de l'europe il faut leur
montrer en fait à quel point l'europe
est utile dans leur vie se porte à porte
voulu par la république en marche se
veut pédagogique autour des enjeux de
l'union européenne notamment après les
57 % d'abstention lors des élections
européennes de 2014 en france un taux de
près de 54% dans les yvelines
le département des yvelines travaille
d'ailleurs avec un fonds social pour
l'europe
on a aujourd'hui 18 millions d'euros
avec lequel donc des fonds européens qui
permettent aux départements de
travailler pour faire en sorte qu'il y
ait moins de pauvreté au niveau du
département donc l'europe est présente
au quotidien dans les yvelines
l'europe concerne les gens de plusieurs
manières les financements la protection
des consommateurs la protection de la
santé la protection des libertés à peu
près 40% des lois auxquelles vous
obéissez nous obéissons elles sont
écrites voté à bruxelles et seulement
transposé dans le droit français
la campagne du parti présidentiel ne
fait que commencer les élections
européennes se tiendront fin mai 2019
pour élire 74 eurodéputés français